i think you've probably heard the word
divide before where someone tells you to
divide something up divide the money
between you and your brother or or
between you and your buddy and it
essentially means to cut up something so
let me write down the word divide
divide so if we had let's say that i
have
four quarters let me see do my best to
draw the quarters
if i have four quarters just like that
well you know that's my rendition of
george washington on the quarters
and let's say there's two of us and
we're going to divide the quarters
between us so this is me right here let
me try my best to draw me
so that's me right there
oh let's see i have a lot of hair
and then this is you
right there
do my best say you're bald
but you have sideburns
maybe that looks more let's see
maybe you have a little bit of a beard
i don't want to get too focused on the
drawing and so that's you that's me and
we're going to divide these four
quarters between the two of us so notice
we have four quarters
four quarters and we're going to divide
between the two of us there are two of
us two of us and i wanna stress the
number two so we're gonna divide four
quarters by two we're gonna divide it
between the two of us and you've
probably done something like this what
happens well each of us are going to get
two quarters so let me divide it we're
going to divide it into two essentially
what i do is i take the four quarters
and i divide it into two equal groups
two
equal groups and that's what division is
we cut up this group of quarters into
two equal groups so when you divide four
quarters into two groups so this was
four quarters right there
let me
so that was four
quarters and you want to divide it into
two groups this is group 1
group
1 right here
and this is group 2 right here
how many numbers
are in each group or how many quarters
are in each group well in each group i
have one
two quarters i need to use a brighter
color i have one two quarters in each
group one quarter and two quarters in
each group so to write this out
mathematically i think this is something
that you've done probably as long as
you've been uh splitting money between
you and your siblings and your your
buddies actually let me scroll over a
little bit so you can see my entire
picture
so what how do we write this
mathematically we can write we can write
that four
divided by
so this four let me use the right colors
so this four
which is this four
divided by the two groups
so the two groups these are the two
groups group one and this is group two
right here so divided into two groups or
into two collections four divided by two
is equal to
when you divide four by into two groups
each group is going to have two quarters
in it it's going to be equal to 2. and i
just wanted to use this example because
i want to show you that division is
something that you've been using all
along
and another important i guess takeaway
or thing to realize about this is on
some level this is the opposite of
multiplication if i said that i had two
groups
if i said that i had two groups
of two quarters i would multiply the two
groups times the two quarters each
times the two quarters each and i i
would say i would then have four
quarters
so on some level these are saying the
same thing but just to make it a little
bit more concrete in our head let's do a
couple of more examples
let's do a bunch of more examples
so let's write down what is
six
divided by
i'll try to keep it nice and color coded
six divided by three what does that
equal to
let's just draw six objects
they can be anything let's say i have
six
six bell peppers i won't take too much
trouble to draw them well that's not
what a bell pepper looks like but you
get the idea so one
two
three
four
five six and i'm going to divide it by
three and one way that we can think
about that is that means i want to
divide my six bell peppers into three
equal groups of bell peppers you could
kind of think of it if three people are
going to share these bell peppers how
many do each of them get so let's divide
into three groups so that's our six bell
peppers i'm going to divide into three
groups so the best way to divide into
three groups is i could have one group
right there
two groups
or the second group right there and then
the third group
and then each group
each group will have exactly how many
bell peppers they'll have one two
one two
one two bell peppers so six divided by
three is equal
is equal to two so the best way or one
way to think about it is that you
divided the six into three groups
now you could view that
a slightly different way although it's
it's not completely different but it's a
good way to think about it you could
also think of it as six
divided by
three and once again let's say i have uh
well let's say i have raspberries now
easier to draw one two three four
five six and here instead of drawing
instead of dividing it into three groups
like we did here right this was one
group two group three groups instead of
dividing into three groups what i want
to do is say well if i'm dividing six
divided by three i want to divide it
into groups of three not into three
groups i'm going to divide into groups
of three so how many groups of three am
i going to have
well let me let me draw some groups of
three so that is one group of three
and that is two groups of three
that is two groups of three right there
so if i take six things and i divide
them into groups of three i will end up
with one two groups so that's another
way to think about division and this is
an interesting thing when you think
about these two relations you'll see a
relationship between 6 divided by 3 and
6 divided by 2.
let me do that right here what is 6
divided by
6 divided by 2 when you think of it in
this context right here
6 divided by 2 when you do it like that
let me draw 1 2 3 4 5 6. well we think
about 6 divided by 2 in terms of
dividing it into two groups what we can
end up is we could have one group like
this
and then one group like this
and each group will have three elements
it'll have three things in it so six
divided by two is three or you can think
of it the other way you could say that 6
divided by
2
is you're taking 6 objects 1 2 3 4 5 6
and you're dividing it into groups of 2
where each group has two elements and
that on some level is an easier thing to
do if each group has two elements well
that's one right there
i could even they don't even have to be
nicely ordered this could be one group
right there and that could be the other
group right there i don't have to draw
them all stacked up these are just
groups of two but how many groups do i
have i have one two three i have three
groups
but notice something it's no coincidence
that six divided by three is two six
divided by 3 is 2 and 6 divided by 2 is
3. let me write that down
we get
6 divided by 3 is equal to 2
and 6 divided by 2 is equal to three and
the reason why these you see this
relation where you can kind of swap
this two and this three
is because
two times three is equal to six if i
have
if i have let's say i have two groups of
three
let me draw two groups of three so
that's one group of three
and then here's another group of three
right that's one group of three and
that's another group of three so two
groups of three is equal to six
two times three is equal to six
or you could think of it the other way
if i have three groups of two so that's
one group of two right there i have
another group of two right there and
then i have a third group of two right
there what is that equal to
three
groups of two three times two that's
also equal to six
so two times three is equal to six three
times two is equal to six we saw this in
the multiplication video that the order
doesn't matter but that's the reason why
if you want to divide it if you want to
go the other way if you have 6 things
and you want to divide it into groups of
2 you get 3. if you have 6 and you want
to divide into groups of three you get
two let's do a couple of more problems
and i think it'll really make sense
about what division is all about
so let's do
let's do
9
let's do an interesting one let's do 9
divided by
4.
so if we think about 9 divided by 4 let
me draw 9 objects 1 2 3
4
5 6
7 eight
nine
now when you divide by four i'm gonna
say in this in this for this problem
think about into dividing it into groups
of four so if i want to divide it into
groups of four let me try doing that so
here is
one group of four i just picked any of
them right like that that's one group of
four
then here's another group of four
right there
and then i have this leftover thing
maybe we could call it a remainder where
i don't have i can't divide put this one
into a group of four when i'm dividing
by four i can only put i can only cut up
the nine into groups of four so the
answer here and this is a new concept
for you maybe
nine divided by four
is going to be two groups right i have
one group here another group here and
then i have a remainder of one i have
one left over that i wasn't able to do
with remainder
remainder
that says remainder 1. 9 divided by 4 is
2 remainder 1. if i asked you what 12
divided by 4 is let me do 12. 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11
12. so let me write that down 12
divided
by 4. so i want to divide these 12
objects maybe they're apples or plums
and divide them into groups of four so
let me see if i can do that
so this is one group of four
just like that
this is another group of four
just like that and this is pretty
straightforward then i have a third
group of four
just like that and there's nothing left
over like i had before that i can
exactly divide 12 objects into
three groups of four right one two
three groups of four so 12 divided by
four
is equal to is equal to
3. and we could do the exercise that we
saw in the previous video what is 12
divided by 3
let me do a new color
12
divided by 3. now based on what we
learned so far we say oh that should
just be 4 because 3 times 4 is 12. but
let's prove it to ourselves so 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12. let's divide it into
groups of three
and i'm going to make them a little
strange looking just so you see that you
don't always have to do it into nice
clean columns so that's a group of 3
right there 12 divided by 3 let's see
here is a
here's another group of three
just like that
and then maybe i'll take this group of
three
like that and then i'll take this group
of three there's obviously a much easier
way of dividing it up and doing these
weird l-shaped things but i want to show
you it doesn't matter you're just
dividing it into groups of three and how
many groups do we have we have one group
and then we have our second group
right here and then we have our third
group
right there and then we have let me do
it in a new color and then we have our
fourth group right there so we have
exactly
four groups and when i say there was an
easier way to divide the easier way was
obviously
maybe not obviously
if i wanted to divide these into groups
of three i could have just done one
two
three
four groups of three either of these i'm
dividing the 12 objects into packets of
three you can imagine them that way
let's do another one that maybe has a
remainder
let's see
what is
what is 14
divided by divided by five
so let's draw 14 objects
14 objects 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
14 objects and i'm going to divide into
groups of five
so let me draw well the easiest thing is
there's one group right there
two groups right there
but then this last one i only have four
left so i can't make another group of
five so the answer here is i can make
two groups of five and i'm gonna have a
remainder r for remainder of four
two remainder four now
once you get enough practice you're not
always going to be wanting to draw these
circles and dividing them up like that
although that would not be incorrect so
another way to think about this type of
problem is to say well 14 divided by 5.
how do i figure that out
and actually another way of writing this
and no no harm in
showing you i could say 14 divided by 5
is the same thing as 14
divided by this sign right here divided
by 5. and what you do is you say well
let's see how many times does 5 go into
14
well let's see five times and you kind
of do multiplication tables in your head
five times one is equal to five
five times two is equal to ten so that's
still less than fourteen so five goes at
least two times
five times 3 is equal to 15. well that's
bigger than 14 so i have to go back here
so 5 only goes 2 times so it goes 2
times 2 times 5 is 10
and then you subtract you say 14 minus
10 is 4 and that's the same remainder is
right here
well i could divide 5 into 14 exactly 2
times which would give us 2 groups of 5
which is essentially just 10 but we
still have the 4 left over
we still have
the 4 left over just like that let me do
a couple of more just to really make
sure you you get this stuff really
really really really well
so let's say that i have
let me write it in that notation let's
see how i would do 8
divided by 2. and i could also write
this as 8 so i want to know what that is
that's a question mark i could also
write this as
8
divided by
2. and the way i do either of these i'll
draw the circles in the second but the
way i do it without doing a second
without drawing the circles i say well 2
times 1
is equal to 2 so that definitely goes
into 8 but maybe i can think of a larger
number that goes into
that when i multiply it by two still
goes into eight two times two is equal
to four that's still less than eight
so two times three is equal to six still
less than eight
two times
two times something weird happened with
my pen 2 times
4 is exactly equal to 8. so 2 goes into
8 4 times so i could say 2 goes into 8 4
times or 8 divided by 2 is equal to 4.
we can even draw our circles one two
three four five six seven eight i drew a
messy on purpose and let's divide them
into groups of two
i have one group of two
two groups of two
three groups of two
four groups of twos if you have eight
objects divide them into groups of two
you have four groups so eight divided by
two is four eight divided by two is four
hopefully you found that helpful